we live in a great country at this
statue we're in Afghanistan it would
have been destroyed by now when they
asked me back in January if I would host
the Oscars the first thought that came
into my mind was would there be enough
time for my facelift to heal thank you
astronauts by the way that introduction
cost the government one trillion dollars
so there goes your tax cut but I wanted
a nice intro so the astronauts are
watching the show from over 200 miles up
and right now all over the world there
are 800 million people watching us right
now and every one of them is thinking
the exact same thought that we're all
gay
but that is what is great about show
business it's a tolerant business it's
the it's the most tolerant in the world
you have black people white people
Asians Hispanics Jews Christians all
working together all because of a single
common love publicity now many of you
people in the audience I've worked with
not in movies but at parties I love your
last film oh and you loved mine oh
thanks there's Ellen Burstyn Ellen
Burstyn has
please hold your applause until it's for
me
Ellen Burstyn did something that not
many actresses would do for a role in
the movie she made herself look 30
pounds heavier and 20 years older and
Russell Crowe still hit on her
I think we're always on opposite sides
of the stage actually Kate Hudson 21
years old
I love welcoming the young stars to show
business because it reminds me of my own
death
okay don't you find it strange when you
first start to be famous I mean we get
so many things we don't deserve to get
free tickets you get moved to the front
of the line
would you like a new liver yes mr.
Martin were like it give me that and
it's so strange when you first start to
get recognized like in the supermarket
are you Steve Martin or at the airport
are you Steve Martin or making love are
you Steve Martin good people say to me
Steve you're a Hollywood actor
you must be so separated from the world
how do you keep in touch with ordinary
life well it is possible and it can be
done like the other day I was having
dinner at my house with Mel Julia Tom
and Gwyneth now earlier Mel had called
and wanted to bring a friend you know
some guy who helps children
and I said Mel let's just keep it names
above the title and he understood he was
fine with that and then Tom said you
know you just can't get decent
sunglasses anymore and Julia said well
there's a great sunglasses shop in
Beverly Hills so I said that Tom you
know the next time you have your driver
drop your kids off at school why don't
you have them pick you up a pair of
sunglasses and Tom said well I dropped
my kids off at school and I said what
and then Tom said to gwyneth that he
loved Shakespeare in Love and then
Gwyneth said to Tom that she loved
castaway and then Julia said to Mel that
she loved what women want and Mel said
to Julia that he loved Erin Brockovich
and then it was late and they all went
home and I thought this is what I've
always dreamed about dinner at home with
friends where we discussed the Arts
now look how beautiful Julia Roberts
looks Julia
Julie I miss our phone calls but it
seems like ever since you got caller ID
you're never home
designers now rush to provide clothes
and jewels for people attending the
Oscars this tuxedo was given to me by a
famous designer provided I mentioned
their name on the show and then the
producer said you can't do that this is
not the white house you're going to have
to
you're going to have to pay for your
tuxedo so I didn't know what to do I was
in a moral dilemma so I called my friend
Giorgio Armani see how are we doing on
time oh we got five hours um
see
there's Javier Bardem who gave
we gave such a brilliant performance in
a movie about a homosexual poet
persecuted by hostile military forces a
movie the rapper Eminem called the
feel-good movie of the year and there's
Charlton Heston
be careful what you say to him because
he thinks he was in Gladiator
and there's Tom Hanks and by the way
it's interesting if Tom wins tonight
that means between Tom and myself we
will have three Best Actor
and Tom and Rita have one of the most
enduring marriages in show business and
it is not easy to keep a marriage
together in Hollywood because well we
sleep with so many different people
here's yes
there's Angley director
director of Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon not first I didn't realize that
was a movie
because to me Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon sounds like something Siegfried
and Roy do on vacation
um
ticket prices went to $10 in New York
and I understand why Julia but I'm
concerned because you know the audience
the audience still has valid complaints
and we have to listen to them one they
feel that the trailer gives away too
much of the movie like I saw the trailer
to dude where's my car
and it ruined it for me now maybe that's
not fair because I had read the book but
maybe critics are right maybe Hollywood
movies are too violent now I took a
nine-year-old kid to see gladiator and
he cried through the entire film now
maybe it was because he didn't know who
I was
you know you know what I've just
realized that hosting the Oscars is like
making love to a beautiful woman it's
something I only get to do and Billy
Crystal is out of town well
thank you